can you explain much further
clarification judge would mean beyond
what Attorney General Holder yeah i'm
not sure what judge who needs I don't
I'm not I'm not entirely certain I'm so
so I know I can't answer that if you're
a step forward in this case to make a
recommendation about sex every single
juror that we've spoken to every single
juror I think we've spoken to nine of
the 12 and we've spoken to somewhere
between 15 and 20 prospective jurors who
were dismissed by the government every
single juror has asked for a
probationary sentence every 10 people do
make a big deal about the minor issue I
think that's something we heard from a
minor his name is sergeant Zachary
Stotts he's a soldier fighting in the
hundred first airborne division in
Afghanistan and he submitted a video
tape he discusses that distinction a lot
of people you're going to hear the press
secretary for the DOJ and hear talk
about Charlie selling to minors that is
absolutely true but state law is
different than federal law under federal
law sergeant Stotts who's serving in the
military in Afghanistan is a minor under
state law he could come in if he had a
prescription from a doctor and by
medicinal marijuana from Charles linch
period that's the truth so really that
is such a misconception that somehow
Charlie was violating state law because
he was selling to minors that's just for
lack of a better word that's a lie you
have at least the statements that we've
heard so far from Attorney General
Holder
indicate that somehow state law is now
relevant to these prosecutions well the
government as everyone here who covered
the trial knows argued for days to keep
state law out of it and the reason they
did that is because Charlie was in
complete compliance with state law and
we're now asking for the adults in
Washington DC not the locals in here to
recognize the will of the people of the
state of California and we're asking
them to do it because it's the right
thing to do we're asking them to do it
because it's actually now got the
political will it's clearly it's clear
now that the feds have been on the wrong
side of history for some time but most
importantly we're asking that the Obama
administration take a look at this for
one reason and that's because Charles
Lynch is not Pablo Escobar Charles Lynch
is the most decent man who has ever been
prosecuted in this building are you
hopeful about the judges request from
the Department of Justice that he wants
to know if there has been a change
you know it's our understanding that mr.
Ogden who is the I guess at this point
the first guy first man under eric
holder he was a great guy we all love
him here we are we understand that he
was sworn in I think six business days
ago yeah I think it's fair to say that
they're busy they've got Guantanamo
they've got staked secrets issues
they've got torture to deal with and I
think it's fair that medical marijuana
is not necessarily that high up on their
list but it's high up on our list
because we represent Charlie Lynch he's
really truly the nicest guy I've said it
before I'll say it again he is the
nicest man to not only be prosecuted in
this building but to be subject to
direct just outrageous outrageous
federal sentences that in his case could
lead to a prison sentence of decades
well I was definitely glad to hear the
judge talk about the new policy that's
what the new administration's been
talking about hopefully some of that
will help me in my case I feel like
we're we're teetering on the cusp of
change here and the war against the the
people the civil war against the state
medical marijuana States has to end
somewhere and hopefully it's going to be
ending real soon and I'd be glad I'd be
honored to be one of the last persons
you know to be prosecuted and and so we
can end this war against the people you
know who voted in favor this and I
definitely thank all my supporters who
showed up my attorneys my family I've
gotten a lot of support from across the
nation to cost the world even and I
thank everybody for that
I'm hoping that Judge movies finds it
some cash compassion in his heart on the
new sentencing date and and just
let's meet not that doesn't send me the
jail basically